some dangerous weather sweeping Across
the Western half of the U.S as we speak
a massive winter storm it's already
dropped more than five feet of snow in
some areas and there are blizzard
warnings in effect across multiple
States it stretches thousands of miles
and it's headed for the plain states as
we speak Manuel Wilkes is there in Fort
Morgan Colorado Manny good morning how's
it looking Where You Are
well the snow has been coming down here
for the last several hours and there's a
wind that's coming with it that at times
just whips up and makes things miserable
people in this area can expect to see
about nine inches of snow and experience
some whiteout conditions which is the
reason for all of those warnings
officials telling people here listen you
may be used to snow but don't take this
storm lightly
National Weather Service has termed this
storm as a life-threatening event Morgan
County Sheriff here in Colorado has a
warning for residents stay home and off
the roads but before hunkering down many
headed to stores with shovels snow
blowers and salt flying off the shelves
heaters hand warmers just everything I
think people are kind of preparing for
it preparing for the same storm system
that has already battered Northern
California
parts of the Sierra Nevada were
blanketed with nearly six feet of snow
when we opened the garage doors there
was about five feet of snow so it was
kind of like swimming out into the snow
right out of the garage door
as the storm makes its way across the
country a rare sight in Arizona
under snow lighting up the Sedona Sky
coupled with a steady stream of flurries
in Northern Utah the icy roads and
whiteout conditions ran this charter bus
off the highway Monday morning and sent
22 people to the hospital remember
putting my head down bracelet for impact
screaming yellow and hollering people on
the ground people nobody able to move
back here in Morgan County officials
anticipate the storm will lead to school
and business closures with up to 50 to
60 mile an hour winds blowing snow out
on the Eastern Plains when it's blowing
snow like that it drifts becomes very
dangerous in whiteout conditions
and conditions will not be improving
here at least not quickly that blizzard
warning is in effect until midnight
tonight Nate
try to stay warm if you can Manny thank
you